this has been the flashpoint of
Saturday's protests where protesters
have been trying to stop government
forces opening up the after iron bridge
this is the bridge that leads to Tahrir
Square and we've been meeting people and
talking to people who feel that they've
been betrayed by the satirist who left
these camps they are saying they're
going to continue their protest there
have been multiple reports of injuries
and some are saying that people have
been wounded by not just live fire but
also by tear gas canisters that the
government forces are aiming towards
their health we are protesting against
the corrupt government the Iranian
government so to speak they doesn't
represent us at all we didn't vote for
them the militias they are corrupt they
are Iranian they are iranian-backed
militias we call on the United Nations
to intervene and help us from them so
you see they are assassinating us
kidnapping us and killing us all lots of
our activist political activists are
disappearing every day so we want the
help of our of the world
other places around since Friday night
security forces have been opening up
roads and bridges this is one of the
cams which was allegedly burned by the
security forces as they came in towards
target square those are the allegations
by by the protesters here who say that
they will continue their protest they're
going to stay here until the demands are
met